you also oversaw the human genome
project you mean you mentioned the brain
initiative which has
you know it's a it's a dream to map
the human brain and there's the dream to
map the the human code which was the
human genome project and you have said
that it is humbling for me and awe
inspiring to realize that we have caught
the first glimpse of our own instruction
book
previously known only to god
how does that if you can just kind of
wax poetic for a second
how does it make you feel that we were
able to
map this instruction book look into our
own code
and be able to
reverse engineer it
it's breathtaking
it's so fundamental
and yet for all of human history we're
ignorant of the details
of what that instruction book looked
like
and then we crossed the bridge
into the territory of the known
and we had that in front of us still
written in a language that we had to
learn how to read and we're in the
process of doing that and will be for
decades to come but we owned it we had
it
and it has such profound consequences
it's it's both a book about
our history
um it's a book of sort of the parts list
of a human being the genes that are in
there and how they're regulated
and it's also a medical textbook
that can teach us things
that will provide answers to illnesses
we don't understand
and alleviate suffering and premature
death so
it's a pretty amazing thing to
contemplate
and it has utterly transformed the way
we do science and it is in the process
of transforming
the way we do medicine although much of
that still lies ahead
you know
while we were working on the genome
project it was sort of hard
to get this sense of
a wellness because it was just hard work
and you were getting you know another
megabase okay this is good
but when did you actually step back and
say we did it
it's
the profoundness of that i mean there
were two points i guess
one was the announcement on that june 26
2000 where the whole world heard well we
don't quite have it but we got a pretty
good draft
and suddenly people are like realizing
oh
this is this is a big deal
um for me it was more when we got the
full analysis of it published it in
february 2001 in that issue of nature
paper that eric lander and bob waterston
and i were the main authors and we
toiled over
and tried to get as much insight as we
could in there about what the meaning of
all this was
but you also had this sense that we are
such beginning readers here we are still
in kindergarten trying to make sense out
of this 3 billion letter book
and we're going to be at this for
generations to come
you